اهلا بكم في حوار
ضيفنا اليوم صحفي المخضرم وضلع في شؤون
العالم العربي بمشرقه وايضا بمغربه اهلا
وسهلا بك على فخمه
هذا الكتاب قطر اسرار نفوذ على المستوى
الكوني 100 سؤال حول هذا النفوذ صدر لك
ايضا في السنوات الماضيه ثلاثه كتب حول
قطر قطر بيبرس قطر الخزنه وايضا اعزاؤنا
الامراء لماذا التركيز علاقت قطر
لكويت المملكه العربيه السعوديه الامارات
العربيه
كاس العالم لكن هو البلد يثير الاهتمام
يجذب لانه بلد معجزه ولديه كذلك جهات من
الظلام
وامر يجذب الجميع
في العام 71 هناك رجل في قلبه هذه النهضه
القطريه ان صح التعبير وهو الامير الوالد
حمد بن خليفه الثاني همم تقول تصفه بانه
بعيد النظر وبانه انت هذه لماذا هذا الشخص
بهذه النهضه في قطر بالنسبه
لديه رؤيه
قطر على خريطه
شيخ خليفه
[موسيقى]
يظهرون
في كل مكان لكي يثبت وجود قطر بجانبي
جيرانه الاثريه عن قطر تحدثت عن
الدبلوماسيه القطريه قلت بانها تستعمل
دفتر الشيكات وقلت بانها تستعمل ايضا
النفوذ المخملي
والقوه الناعمه في همم عده مجالات في
الرياضه في الثقافه في الاعلام همم ولكن
همم ما يعاب عن قطر هو ضمن سياسه
الدبلوماسيه او نفود الديبلوماسيه لاي
دوله لماذا يعاقب هذا على قطر ولا يعب على
دول اخرى مثلا
بسبب حرب الخليج 990 والشيخ محمد بن خليفه
الثاني
همم
رجلا ولكنه ضعيف بالمقارنه مع جيش ايران
المملكه العربيه السعوديه اذا بدا بسياسه
نفوذ من خلال ربط
علاقات
من خلال الاستثمار الى اخره وما ان تكون
هناك اشكاليه يتصل بهذه البلدان وعندما
كان هناك حصار بين 2017 و20122 على قطر
قطر كان محاصرانيه
فرنسا
همم الرئيس الايراني
[موسيقى]
بتاعه اذا هذه الازدواجيه من جهه العائله
الحاكمه مثلا فرانكفونيه ومنفتحه وشيخه
مياسه يعني رائده في مجال المتاحف الى غير
ذلك ومن جهه اخرى قطر تمول الاسلام
السياسي الاخوان المسلمين وهي مرتبطه في
عقيدتها منذ نشاه بالوهابيه كيف نفسر هذا
امورك
نافع عن النساء
مزدوجه
خلال الثوره العربيه قطر من خلال
الجزيره وهي تستعملها كاجوت ترغيب ونصوص
في مصر في سوريا
[موسيقى]
الذي
في سوريا فرنسا
مره ثانيه
شهر العسل فتح هذا الاستجابه فرنسا من
خلال الاستثمار بس هو صديق مع الشيخ
خليفه كانت هناك علاقه
[موسيقى]
تركيا تركيا
ويقول بان فرنسا لا تضيي عن امتنانها
25 مليار
يوروبين
الامارات العربيه المتحده
لكاس العالم تنظيم هذا الحدث الرياضي
الهام وغير المسبوق بالنسبه لبلد عربي
وبلد اسلامه هو حق يعني هو يعني حدث كبير
همم وكل العرب والمسلمين يفتخرون به هناك
نظره همم في الدول العربيه ليس فقط في قطر
الى كل هذا الجدل هنا في فرنسا وهذه
الانتقادات لكاس العالم في قطر وينظر
اليها بانها معاهدات للاسلام واسلام فوبيا
فهل من الصواب مقاطعه كاس العالم في قطر
الجيده
دقيقه دقيقه
تنتقدوننا لانها اول كاس عالم تنظم في بلد
العربي ومسلم ولكن صحيح
النظره مختلفه ما يحدث هو ان الفضيحه
مصدرها
من القاهره
تقريبا او لبنان سوزو صغيره وما لقطر
تقاليد رياضيه او كرويه وفجاه تفوز بكاس
العالم
الصغير والتحدي العالمي لكاس العالم
العربي
اه
بلانه كانت هناك
فساد رشاوي
هذا البلد الصغير الذي سيحصل اكبر فعاليه
رياضيه مع الالعاب الاولمبيه سؤال اخير في
كلمه هل ستذهب الى قطر لتفرج على كاس
العالم
المصالح الفرنسيه
الملاعب والارضيات يتم تدفئتها الى هناك
النوع من النفاق عندما ينتقد البعض قطر
ولكن في فرنسا
[موسيقى]